[Applause]
thank you let me start off with a
fantasy a fantasy I've had it involves
well I've overpowered his Elite Guard
I've fought my way into a secret bunker
and I've managed to knock his Luger out
of his hand his cyanide pill that he
keeps to commit suicide rather than be
captured he snarls at me he comes at me
in a rage we wrestle I managed to pin
him down put handcuffs on him and then
say Adolf Hitler I arrest you for crimes
against humanity
this is where the the Medal of Honor
version of this fantasy ends and the
imagery begins to darken what would I do
if I actually had Hitler in my hands and
it's not hard to imagine once I allow
myself sever his spine up I don't know
can I is this on now it's on okay so not
hard to imagine once I allow myself
sever his spine at the neck take out his
eyes with a blunt instrument puncture
easier drums cut out his tongue leave
him alive on a respirator
you know tube-fed not able to move not
able to speak not able to hear to see
just to feel and then inject him with
something cancerous that will infest
every single cell in his body now I've
had this fantasy since I was a kid and I
still do sometimes and when I really
think about it my heart beats faster and
it's all these plans for like the most
evil wicked soul in history except
there's a problem which is I don't
believe in Souls and I don't believe in
evil
and I think wicked is only appropriate
for a musical but on the other hand
there's there's all sorts of people I
wouldn't mind seeing killed but I'm
against the death camp penalty but I
watch all sorts of violent schlocky
movies but I'm for very strict gun
control but then there was this one time
I was in a laser tag place tonight such
a good time hiding in a corner
shooting people over and over until this
like pimply kids at me like a million
times in a row and then snickered at me
and made me feel they on manly so
essentially what is obvious here is I'm
your typical human when it comes to this
extremely confusing topic of violence
now obviously as a species we have
problems with violence we have used
shower heads to deliver poison gas
letters with anthrax passenger planes as
weapons mass rape as a military strategy
we are a miserably violent species but
there's a complication with that which
is we don't hate violence
we hate the wrong kind of violence
because when it's the right kind we leap
in we pay good money to watch it we hand
out medals we vote for we mate with the
people who are masters at it when it's
the right kind of violence we love it
and there's an additional complication
because amid us being this miserably
violent species we're also a
extraordinarily compassionate and
altruistic one so how do you begin to
make sense of us the biology of us at
our best moments and our worst moments
and all those ambiguous ones in between
now one thing that is clear is it is
utterly boring to understand the biology
of the motoric aspects of your behavior
your brain tells your spine tells your
muscles to do something and hooray
you've behaved
what's incredibly complicated is
understanding the meaning of the
behavior because in one setting firing a
gun is some appalling act in another
it's an act of like heroic
self-sacrifice in one setting putting
your hand on top of someone else's is
deeply compassionate another it's a deep
betrayal the challenge for us is to
understand the biology of the context of
our behaviors and that one is really
really challenging and one thing that's
clear is you are never going to really
understand what's going on if you get it
into your head that you're going to be
able to explain everything with this is
the part of the brain or the gene z
hormone or the childhood experience or
the
evolutionary mechanism that explains
everything because it doesn't work that
way
instead any behavior that occurs is the
outcome of the biology that occurred a
second before an hour before and all the
way to a million years before okay so if
you give you some sense of this okay so
you're in some situation there's a
crisis there is a crisis there's rioting
violence going on people running around
and there's a stranger running at you in
an agitated state and you can't quite be
sure what their facial expression is
maybe they're angry maybe they're
frightened maybe it's threatening
they've got something in their hand that
seems like a handgun and you're standing
there and you have a gun and they come
running at you and you shoot and then it
turns out that what they had in their
hand was a cell phone instead and thus
we asked a biological question why did
that behavior occur in you and what's
really the central point is that's a
whole hierarchy of questions why did
that behavior occur what went on one
second before in your brain that brought
about that behavior now to begin to
understand that the part of the brain
that's at the top of the list of usual
suspects is a brain region called the
amygdala you want to think about
aggression and think about the brain you
think about the amygdala if you
stimulate the amygdala and an
experimental lab animal you get an
outburst of aggression humans who have
rare types of seizures that start there
rare types of tumors based on the
amygdala uncontrollable violence if you
damage the amygdala you blunt the
ability of an organism to be aggressive
okay so the amygdala is about violence
except if you sit down your typical and
mcdowell adjust and ask them what the
amygdala is about that's not the first
word that's going to come out of their
mouths because for most people studying
at what the amygdala is about is fear
fear and anxiety and learning to be
afraid in other words we've just learned
something very interesting which is you
cannot understand the first thing about
the neurobiology of violence without
understanding the neurobiology of fear
a world in which no amygdaloid neuron
need be afraid there'd be an awful lot
more of us sleeping between lions and
labs now the thing to begin to make
sense of with the amygdala is what parts
of the brain does a talk to and which
regions talks to it in turn now next
region that is incredibly interesting is
called the insular cortex
now the insular cortex is in fact
incredibly boring if you're a lab rat or
any other mammal on earth because it
does something very straightforward you
bite into a piece of food and it's
spoiled and rotten and set it and rancid
in all of that and what happens is as a
result your insular cortex activates and
it triggers all sorts of reflexes your
stomach lurches you gag you spit it out
you have a gag reflex very useful it
keeps mammals from eating poisonous
foods and you do the same thing with
human get a nice human volunteer who
inexplicably is convinced to bite into
this food that's rancid and disgusting
and there in a brain scanner and they're
insular cortex activates we do something
fancier all we have to do is think about
eating something disgusting and the
installed cortex activates but then
something much more subtle
sit down someone in your brain scanner
and have them tell you about a time they
did something miserable and rotten into
some other human or tell them about some
other occurrence of some human doing
something miserable and rotten to
somebody else and the insular cortex
will activate and every other mammal on
earth it does gustatory disgust but in
us it also does moral disgust and what
that tells you is why it is if something
is sufficiently morally appalling we
feel sick to our stomachs it leaves a
bad taste in our mouths we feel soiled
by it we feel nauseous we feel because
our brain invented the symbolic thing of
moral mores and standards some forty
fifty thousand years ago and didn't
invent a new part of the brain at the
time and instead there was presumably
some sort of big committee meeting and
they said okay
moral disgust there's there's that
insulator that does like food discuss
this okay it's in their portfolio now
give me some duct tape the insular
cortex is now going to do moral disgust
as well and it has trouble telling the
difference and no surprise the main part
of the brain the insular cortex talks to
you in the human brain is the amygdala
because once it decides this thing is
disgusting you're a couple of steps away
from it being scary it being menacing it
being something you need to act against
now in lots of ways it's very cool the
insular cortex does this because suppose
you see some moral ill that needs to be
cured in some of the time that can take
enormous self-sacrifice that could take
the ultimate sacrifice in some cases and
if moral outrage was this abstraction
this just the sort of distance sort of
state it would be hard to pick up a head
of steam to really be able to act
against it the visceral your stomach
churning that's where the force comes to
to make a moral imperative imperative
that's great but then there's a downside
because the insular cortex is not very
good at remembering it's only a metaphor
that you were feeling disgusted and
suddenly you have that whole problem of
the world of people who are disgusted by
somebody's behavior which in somebody
else's eyes is just a normal loving
lifestyle disgust is a moving target in
time and space and there's the danger to
decide that being morally disgusted by
something is a pretty good litmus test
for deciding between right and wrong and
we sure know all the ways in which that
can get you into trouble and probably
most of all every ideologue in history
has had a brilliant intuitive feeling
for how the insular cortex works which
is if you can get your minion to the
point that when you talk about them them
living in the next Valley them who think
differently than you who pray
differently who love differently if you
can get your followers to the point that
when you invoke them insular cortex
activate because there is something just
disgusting about them you're 90% of the
way towards pulling
off your successful genocide a key to
every good sort of genocidal movement is
taking them and turning them into being
such infestations and malignancies and
whatever's that they hardly even count
as human anymore okay so we've got this
sort of access between the insular
cortex and the amygdala meanwhile we've
got the most interesting part of the
brain far and away a region called
the frontal cortex frontal cortex I've
just wasted the last 35 years of my life
studying a part of the brain called the
hippocampus which is kind of interesting
and like it's done well by me and I've
been you know that's sort but I wish I'd
been studying the front the frontal
cortex it's the most recently evolved
part of the human brain we've got more
of it than any other species on earth
and what does it do the frontal cortex
makes you do the harder thing when it's
the right thing to do and impulse
control and gratification postponement
and long-term planning and emotional
regulation and what does the frontal
cortex spend an awful lot of time doing
sending inhibitory projections down to
the amygdala hoping to race there in
time to say wait a second are you sure
that's really a handgun wait a second I
wouldn't do that if I were you I know
this seems like a brilliant idea right
now
but believe me you are going to regret
it the frontal cortex is very often
racing to try to control the amygdala
now there's this picture of the frontal
cortex all it does is occasionally go
slumming down the amygdala and preach to
it about like temperance or whatever but
in fact there's bidirectionality
the amygdala has plenty means to talk to
the frontal cortex what's that about
every time we're in a moment of extreme
aroused state and we make a decision
that is hideously stupid and disastrous
that seems brilliant at the time because
that's the frontal cortex being
marinated in what's down below in other
words there's this very tempting view
the frontal cortex most recently evolved
it's this gleaming shining computer
like part of urban it's sitting there
just marinating and all the Emotiv yuck
going on underneath it's bi-directional
communication now finally in terms of
making sense of this frontal cortex the
whole notion of doing the harder thing
when it's the right thing to do is a
value free judgement what do I mean by
this sometimes you have to have an
incredibly strong aerobic lee studly
frontal cortex to resist the temptation
to lie and that's at the centerpiece of
some of the most important sort of
crossroads in our lives however once you
decide that you are going to lie you
need your frontal cortex to do it
effectively because it's your frontal
cortex that says ok remember don't make
eye contact don't use this right cheek
muscle at that point because you're
going to be tempted to twitch keep your
voice under control it could take an
enormous amount of discipline to go and
effectively like make the world whole in
a better place but it can also take an
awful lot of discipline and staying up
late and studying to be effective at
ethnically cleansing villages the
frontal cortex is value free in that
sense ok
so we've gotten a sense of a couple of
the brain regions here that are
pertinent so that's what's going on in
one second before but no brain is an
island and what we now have to do is
take a step back so what was going on in
the seconds two minutes before in the
sensory environment which triggered that
amygdala to do this where that frontal
cortex to do that what are the stimuli
that are coming in there now obviously
in the scenario we have the sight the
sounds of this rioting perfectly
pertinent to making sense there but then
there's a whole world of sensory stuff
going on that's subliminal that you
hardly even know is there and if you did
not in a million thing ears would you
think it's pertinent for example when
you have to make split-second decisions
you are more likely to mistake a cell
phone for a handgun if the person
holding it is male is large is of
another race your brain processes that
in 50 milliseconds
that is one twentieth of a second your
brain is already distinguishing that
incorrectly why is that that turns out
to have a really interesting piece of
the wiring of the amygdala okay so
suppose you look at somebody and there's
something in their hand that's either a
cellphone or handgun so what happens the
information goes from your eye to this
Waystation of the brain and eventually
gets to your visual cortex and a first
layer there sits and spend some time and
figures out what the pixels are and then
the second layer turns the pixels into
lions and the next layer turns the lines
and to curves and eventually you got a
four-dimensional sort of picture where
and then eventually some neurons in your
cortex says oh my I believe that's a
handgun and let's go wake up the
amygdala and let it know about it that's
the simple part it turns out there's a
shortcut the very first way station
where sensory information comes in
shortcuts directly to the amygdala in
other words the amygdala knows there is
a handgun while your visual cortex is
still fussing around with the pixels
there that's very good that's very
helpful that it gets that information
quickly but it turns out you need all
those computational layers in your
visual cortex to tell what's there
accurately in other words the amygdala
gets sensory information that's very
emotionally aroused before your
conscious cortex does and the accuracy
is not great and thus if you're tired if
you're hungry if you're in pain if
there's a bad smell around if any of
those things are happening you are
biasing the amygdala towards you staking
a neutral facial expression for a
threatening one mistaking a cellphone
for a handgun all of that occurring in
the seconds before okay but now we need
to take a step further back what about
hours two days before how was that
affecting how sensitive you are to
sensory information which then talk to
you or make the Limassol cortex all that
what we've moved into here is the realm
of hormones in that regard amid a
gazillion hormones that are pertinent
two of them stand out above all covers
first one the inevitable usual suspect
hormone that's got to be
pulled in at this point which is
testosterone okay what is testosterone
about estas when was the reason why
males in every culture and every species
on earth or such pains in the asses
testosterone causes a gret testosterone
does not cause aggression but
testosterone does is bias you towards
interpreting ambiguous social
information as being threatening as
being provocative take somebody and pump
them up with testosterone and they
decide that neutral facial expressions
seen for 20th of a second or threatening
take testosterone and that grief
exposure to that new full facial
expression and suddenly the amygdala is
all agitated and frothing at the mouth
what testosterone does is it exaggerated
Spri existing tendencies what it does is
sensitize you to whatever social
learning you've received about what kind
of aggression is just fine of what kind
isn't now the single most interesting
thing about testosterone is even that's
not what it really does testosterone
doesn't make organisms more aggressive
what testosterone does is it makes more
organ organisms more likely to do
whatever behavior is needed to hold on
to high status when it's being
challenged okay if you're a baboon what
that means is aggression because if
somebody is threatening you it's going
to be all about aggression that's the
entire world of the baboon remarkably in
humans put somebody in an economic game
where you get high status by being
generous and the offers you make and
testosterone makes people more generous
the problem isn't that testosterone
causes aggression the problem is that we
reward aggression with status so readily
and what that also tells you is if you
took a gazillion Buddhist monks and shot
them up with testosterone they'd be
running around and like frenzied gangs
doing random acts of kindness to see who
could do the most of them most quickly
the problem here is not the hormone it's
the values and the rewards that we place
on aggression okay meanwhile in that
span of hours today's the other hormone
that has just as undeserved of a
reputation but in the opposite direction
is the
hormone oxytocin now oxytocin is
officially to sort of use endocrine
jargon it's officially the grooviest
hormone on earth because oxytocin's by
now-famous it causes bonding between
mothers and infants and pair bonding
between monogamous couples and it makes
you more expressive and emotionally
sensitive and more cooperative and more
charitable and more trusting and there's
a whole new horrifying field of
neuroscience called neuro marketing
where if you spritz oxytocin up people's
noses they're more likely to believe all
sorts of gibberish and nonsense of
people trying to sell you stuff whether
it's their political viewpoint or some
geek off and if they could spray
oxytocin through the vents and like
Costco all over this country what that
would do to the economy of like sort of
the nonsense that people would buy okay
so oxytocin promotes pro-social behavior
until you look more closely and one
recent work shows is that's exactly what
oxytocin does it makes you much more
cooperative and generous and charitable
all of that with people who you
categorize as being just like you it
makes you pour more pro-social towards
in-group members and when it comes to
out group members it makes people more
xenophobic and more preemptively
aggressive and less cooperative and the
greatest study showing this was a couple
years ago and this was a group in the
Netherlands where they got their usual
sort of lab rats which was college
volunteers from some like University
there and what they did was they gave
everyone this standard classic problem
in philosophy the runaway trolley
problem is that okay to sacrifice one
person push him in front of a runaway
trolley to save five and there's a whole
world research done on that so they sort
of established the baseline level also
which people would be willing to push
somebody does say five now what they did
was they gave the person they were
pushing on to the track a name a third
of the time the person would get a name
that apparently is just like your
stereotypical Dutch named Dirk or Peter
or something like that
third of the time or the remainder of
the time either of the two groups that
people in Holland tend to have a lot of
out-group hostility towards Germans oh
that's right World War two or people
with Muslim names so now you've got the
scenario do you push Dirk in front of
the trolley do you push Auto in front of
the trolley do you push Mahmud in front
of the trolley and what they show is
give people oxytocin and there are less
likely to sacrifice Derick words they
can't leap fast enough to push Wolfgang
and our mood there under the tracks
oxytocin doesn't make us nicer and makes
us nicer to people we're already
predisposed towards being nice to it
exaggerated us them contrast okay so now
stepping back further how about weeks
two months before and this is now
entered the realm of neural plasticity
the fact that the brain can change in
response to experience and for example
if you've now just spent these last few
months mired in trauma and stress your
amygdala will have grown larger it will
have form new connections the circuits
there will be more excitable and your
frontal cortex will have become more
sluggish and atrophied in other words at
that critical moment the amygdala is in
a more hysterical hyper reactive State
and the frontal cortex has much of that
much less capacity to get there in time
and say wait a second are you sure
before you pull the trigger there you
can see that changing okay but stepping
back even further now going back years
decades how about adolescence what going
on an adolescent is relevant now to this
one second of whether or not you're
going to pull that trigger and the
central fact of the adolescent brain is
that all of the brain is going full
blast fully mature except for the
frontal cortex which is still half-baked
at that point amazingly the frontal
cortex it's the last part of the brain
to fully mature it is not fully online
until you are about twenty-five years
old which explains an enormous amount of
freshman year in college it's the last
part of the brain to fully mature what
does that mean
it means adolescence and early adulthood
is the time of life where environment
and experience are sculpting your
frontal cortex into the adult version
you are going to have in that one
critical moment they're deciding what
the outcome is what that also tells you
is if this is the last part of the brain
to fully mature it's the part of the
brain least shaped by genes and most
shaped by environment okay but now
stepping even further back how about
back to your childhood back to your
fetal life obviously pertinent because
that's when your brain was being
constructed but what people also have
learned in recent years is experience
experience during that period causes
changes jargon in the field epigenetic
changes causes permanent changes in some
genes and parts of your body or turned
on forever after other genes are turned
off ur lifetime consequences ah
in other words childhood matters this is
one of the molecular mechanisms by which
childhood matters and is a very
pertinent example of that if you have
spent your feet'll nine months being
just baised at high levels of stress
hormones from Mom's circulation because
she is extremely stressed as an adult
thanks to epigenetic changes during your
fetal life your amygdala is going to be
hyper reactive and you're going to
secrete higher levels of stress hormones
which makes the amygdala even more
reactive and makes the frontal cortex
sluggish so events back and fetal life
but going back even further
okay back to when all you were was a
fertilized egg and a bunch of genes
now obviously genes have tons to do with
everything here but here is the great
temptation to decide that genes are
determining anything genes determine
essentially nothing when it comes to
behavior because genes work differently
in different environments and the most
pertinent example here is a gene called
mono Amane monoamine oxidase a mao a do
not even dream of writing that down but
Mao a comes in a bunch of different
flavors a bunch of different variants
and if you have one particular variant
you
are very significantly more likely as an
adult to commit antisocial violence if
and only if you are abused as a child if
you weren't having that gene variant has
zero increase in your risk factor it's
not your genes it's the way the genes
interact with your environment and thus
starting with fetal life the
interactions between genes and
environment are going to shape enormous
Lee what state your brain is in in that
one critical second now do you pull the
trigger or not okay
but you've got to go even further back
past you as a single organism how about
your ancestors what were they up to for
example if your ancestors were
pastoralists people wandering deserts
and grasslands with their herds of
camels or cows or goats the odds are
they would have invented what is called
a culture of Honor
high levels of retributive violent clans
and debt is warrior classes that's the
whole world of if the a come and take
your camel and you do nothing about it
the next day they'll come and take your
entire turd herd and your wives and
daughters to clan violence going on for
centuries and what is clear is if your
ancestors were of a culture of Honor
centuries later that's still influencing
the values with which you are being
raised including within moments of birth
how often mothers are holding their
children so centuries worth of that okay
but steps further back where the
cultural difference is coming from from
ecosystems one example of that you look
at people within deserts and
historically they're likely to come up
with monotheistic religions look at
people and rainforests and they come up
with polytheistic religions look at
people in East Asia who live in flat
plain areas and they grow rice which
requires collectivist farming and you
get a very collectivist mindset about
cooperation get people in the hill
countries there and they grow wheat
which is done in individual families and
you get the same individualistic mindset
that you get in people living in
Manhattan
all of it ecologically shaped but then
we got to go even further back because
you're talking about genes anywhere
along the way you're talking about the
evolution of the genes and what you wind
up seeing is evolution has sculpted
different primate species into having
different characteristic levels of
aggression some primate species have
virtually none at another extreme
immensely high levels and there's all
sorts of biological traits that go along
with the two extremes and what about us
we're somewhere right in the middle
between the two extremes okay so in
other words if you want to understand
why did this behavior occur you've got
to take into account everything from one
second before to a million years before
okay so what do you conclude from that
ooh
it's complicated okay that's very useful
but how about ooh it's complicated and
you better be real careful and real
cautious before you decide you
understand the causes of a behavior
especially if it's behavior that you
hunt judge harshly because things can
really go wrong with the wrong
attributions and we have a very dark
stained history of that occurring
precisely for those reasons now for me
when I look at all of this information
the single thing that I find to be most
important has to do with change every
single biological fact that I've given
along the way here is subject to change
over time ecosystems change thousands of
years ago the Sahara was a lush
grassland filled with hippos and giraffe
cultures change in the 17th century the
scariest people in all of Europe were
the Swedes who spent that whole century
rampaging all over Europe and the Swedes
have not had a war in two hundred and
three years they changed and most of all
brains change circuits form neurons
weakened patterns grow parts of brains
expand pop and as a result people change
and they could change extraordinarily
some examples of it change in people
that can occur over the course of
decades a man who moves me a norm
a man by the name of John Newton he was
a British theologian he was a leading
abolitionist played a central role in
the role in the banning of slavery at
the beginning of the 1800s in England
John Newton spent the early decades of
his adult life as the captain of a slave
ship and after he retired from that he
spent decades as a local parson still
investing in the slave trade and growing
rich from it until one day something
changed in him something changed
something changed and he celebrated it
and the thing that he is most known for
historically in him that he wrote
Amazing Grace
another example an a man named Zen Jia
Bay who on the morning of December 6
1941 was the lead pilot in one of the
Bombardier squadrons that took off from
an Air Force Base in Japan and attacked
Pearl Harbor he was one of their star
pilots he led one of the divisions there
and fifty years later to the day as an
old man he came towards a ceremony at
Pearl Harbor commemorating it as an old
man came forward in broken English and
apologized to some of the elderly
survivors on the ground there and spent
the rest of his life close with some of
them think about that transformation if
one of those men that he befriended had
become a captive is's during World War
two he might have happily walked him to
death in the Bataan Death March and if
he had been a captive of one of those
American men who had killed him he might
very well have taken his skull as a
souvenir which was a standard thing done
in the Pacific during World War two with
dead Japanese and instead fifty years
later he's writing a letter to that
man's grandchildren consoling them when
grandpa has died change can occur even
faster over the course of ours and the
example that just mesmerizes me was the
first winter of world war one the
Christmas truce of 1914 powers-that-be
had worked out a truce that was supposed
to go for a couple of hours and the idea
was along the trenches of France people
would be able to come out and retrieve
bodies from no-man's land and go and
bury them
so German and British troops came out
and retrieved bodies and soon they
helped each other carry the bodies and
soon they helped each other dig graves
in the frozen ground and then they
prayed together over the dead and then
they shared Christmas dinner and then
they exchanged gifts and by the next day
they were playing soccer together up and
down no-man's land
and exchanging addresses to get together
and see each other after the war was
over
and those truces went on for two to
three days until the officers had to
arrive and threatened to shoot these men
unless they went back to killing each
other and all it took was a couple of
hours to completely reorganize these
people's sense of who counts as an
autism of them and us being all of us in
these trenches on both sides dying for
no damn reason and them being the face
was powers behind the lines using us as
just pawns and sometimes change can
occur in the course of seconds two
minutes now historically probably the
single biggest horror in terms of
American consciousness from the Vietnam
War was the malai massacre a brigade of
American soldiers went into an
undefended village full of civilians and
killed between 350 and 500 of them
gang-raped women and girls beforehand
mutilated bodies utterly nightmarish
because it occurred because the US
government covered it up for as long as
possible
because ultimately they just did
slapping of a few wrists and because it
was not a singular incident it was one
of the nightmares of Vietnam War the me
Lai massacre was stopped by one man a
man named Hugh Thompson Thompson was
piloting a helicopter gunship flying
over the village and was seeing American
soldiers firing activity oh they're
under attack by Viet Cong landed there
got out and was viewing the
incomprehensible sight of American
soldiers shooting elderly women digging
out babies from underneath the bodies of
their mothers and shooting them and
figured out what was happening and Hugh
Thompson got into his helicopter and in
the
course of minutes undid every bit of
training he had had as to who is an us
and who is of them
he took his helicopter landed it between
the last group is surviving villagers
there and American soldiers coming at
them with their weapons landed his
helicopter and turned his machine guns
on the American soldiers and said if you
do not stop I will mow you all down and
what is most important to me is none of
these guys had fancier neurons than any
of us same neurotransmitters same genes
same enzymes no fancier than any of us
what I think we're left with here at the
end is a version of like that inevitable
exasperated cliche those who don't study
history are destined to be able to
repeat it what we have here I think is
the opposite those who don't study the
history of extraordinary human change
and those who don't study the science of
how we more readily go from the worst of
our behaviors to the best ones are
destined enough to be able to repeat
unbelievable magnificent moments like
these so let me stop at this point and
if there's any questions okay no okay
it's someone coming to the Michael so
what's happening in the future of
neurology that would give us hope for
understanding the brain better having
better outcomes okay um let me just take
this book here that I happen to see
sitting here let's see I haven't read
this yet but I skimmed it for the
picture okay here's one figure I don't
know if you could particularly see it on
the left page it's a whole bunch of
graphs and the whole point is it's a
bunch of graphs that are doing like this
for a long stretch and then suddenly
they do that what those are are the
number of publications by year in
various topics I talked about for
example at the top one two thousand two
two thousand six two thousand ten two
thousand the number of papers in the
medical literature concerning the topic
of oxytocin and trust everything about
it has been learned in the last ten
years here we have brain and aggression
1985 there were essentially zero papers
published by the last decade more than
two thousand every single one of these
the vast majority of what we've learned
has come in the last whatever short
amount of time we're only a couple of
hundred years into understanding that
epilepsy is a neurological disease and
not demonic possession we're only about
50 years into understanding certain
types of learning disabilities are due
to micro malformations in the cortex and
people with dyslexia and it's not
laziness or lack of motivation
the vast majority these factoids are
1020 years old and all that's going to
happen is we're going to learn more and
more of that stuff and what we're going
to learn more and more is to recognize
the extent to which we are biological
organisms and our behaviors has to be
evaluated in that realm
for my money what that eventually does
is make words like soul or evil utterly
absurd and me evil but it also makes
words like punishment or justice very
questionable as well I think it will
require an enormous reshaping how we
think we deal with the most damaging of
human behaviors because none of it can
be thought of outside the context of
biology well you did mention rashard the
Buddhists but I have a sense that in my
life at least have been exposed to a
number of techniques for creating people
that are like that for example
Buddhists people practice be possible
people who undergo psychoanalysis or
theories activities that come from that
group group relations work or group
therapy there are tools that have that
effect what I'm considering what I'm
wondering about is why those things are
not customary not they're not they're
not institutions we don't have for
example UGC so doesn't have a program to
to cause people in the community to meet
together there are packages that can do
that but it doesn't happen what's why is
that well the easy punchline is because
they're usually really hard to do one
example that comes to mind okay so
you've got conflicting groups that for
decades for millennia have had us to
them die economies in their head have
been at each other's throats and for
decades this notion has been floating
around among psychologists something
called contact theory which is if you
bring people from hostile opposing
groups together and they get to know
each other they're going to recognize
hey we're all the same there and it's
going to be wondrous and we're all going
to be like singing Kumbaya and this is
going to be terrific and that's been the
motivation for all sorts of these
programs taking Palestinian and Israeli
teenagers and putting them in summer
camps Irish kids Northern Irish
Catholics and Protestants all of those
endless versions of these and what that
extremely large literature is shown by
now is when it works right
it absolutely reduces intergroup
conflict can cause lasting changes in
perception where people could generalize
it beyond not just ooh now I know
there's one Israeli I know who's
actually good guy guys could generalize
can generalize you into other groups of
them nonetheless most of the ways in
which you set those settings up wind up
making things worse because it's very
narrow domains where these things I
you've got to get everybody on equal
ground
have to have shared goals they have to
have an absence of any symbols that
reviewed is provocative and if you have
it anything other than that you're going
to make things worse in other words none
of these things are done easily but
they're all workable that's a question
you talked about the critical time of
adolescents in the development of what
we consider right and wrong and how do
you address the generation of coming up
that have been just inundated with
violence within their media within the
video games that they play in the
defense's it served desensitizes them to
acts of violence okay I as a parent and
absolutely horrified by all that stuff
and can easily go off onto a rant about
all the bad consequences of it and I
could find papers now that are looking
at video violence and the desensitizing
affects them and if I really feel like
going down to like the second
sub-basement and sort of the Stanford
Medical Library and pull out journals
from the 60s and there are the exact
same papers there where all you need to
do is replace the word television with
video games television radio violence in
the 1930s with like detective stories of
who knows what
every single generation is wrestled with
us and when you go through the mass of
literature looking at each new
incarnation what you see is on the
average all of those forms of violence
cause a short term burst in violent
behavior and individuals that dis
inhibits it but in terms of whether it
has long-term consequences and every one
of those realms you get a very familiar
punchline violent media makes aggressive
individuals more aggressive it has no
effects on anybody else because what it
does is legitimizes and habituates and
dis inhibits individuals who already
have the predisposition towards just
like testosterone it is not a good
invent aggression it exacerbates
pre-existing social tendencies towards
it so in that regard the good news is
it's no worse than like no cop dramas
sitting by the like fireside chats in
the 1930s with the radio there the bad
effects are nonetheless those who are
vulnerable this is a more visit more
through a more real form of imitating an
awful reality than anything that's been
invented before but the general effects
turn out not to be terribly malevolent
yeah oh hi well in your talk you point
out how complicated it is to explain a
behavior and you know the example you
use with well you could put that the
person with the you know trying to
figure it up the thing in the hands a
gun could be a you know obviously a
police officer I mean it could be
anybody in that situation and a lot of
neuroscience has been brought into the
courtroom I mean for that matter and
brought into the classroom to to try to
you know use a brain scan to explain
something but I wondered in particular
in the courtroom how do you where do you
see that headed you know where people
are bringing brain scandals as well the
brain my brain made me do it rather than
me or whatever um great question
insanely contentious field there's some
very scary smart people I've had to
argue with the times sort of taking the
viewpoints that neurosciences no we're
ready for prime time yet for its
appearance in courts just to give you a
sense of where neuroscience plays a role
in the American criminal justice system
the gold standard for deciding that
somebody who has committed a crime is so
organically impaired that they can't be
held responsible for their acts is if
they basically cannot tell the
difference between right and wrong which
is usually a way of describing extreme
sort of schizophrenic psychosis this is
something called the McNaughton rule and
was based on an individual almost
certainly a paranoid schizophrenic who
delusionally hearing voices
attempted to assassinate the Prime
Minister of England in 1840 that's the
legal standard in the United States
based on neuroscience from 1840 I mean I
don't think horses here to even evolved
brains at that point and that's the
basis by which the legal system works
the area that the legal system in the
United States has incorporated exactly
zero neuroscience is the realm of
volitional impairment the realm of
people who do know the difference
between right and wrong who nonetheless
cannot regulate their behavior where is
that that's when you see damage to the
frontal cortex
and you get somebody there who can tell
you absolutely which is the appropriate
thing to switch for you can switch for
five MMS but you only get one as a
reward or if you reach for one mm you
get five as a reward and they will say
yeah I know how it works I need to reach
for the one because I get much more
eminent and they go for the wrong one at
the last instant when you have frontal
damage you pass the McNaughton test you
know the difference between right and
wrong and nonetheless you cannot
regulate their behavior there is no
state in this country that regularly
accepts volitional impairment defenses
in a criminal court two horrifying
statistics that are pertinent to that 25
percent of the men on death row in this
country have a history of concussive
head trauma to their frontal cortex
other horrifying factoid by the time you
are 5 years old the socioeconomic status
of your parents is a predictor of the
levels of stress hormones in your
bloodstream what do you know it goes in
the direction of the poorer you are the
more stress hormones and the more stress
hormones the less frontal maturation by
kindergarten your SES by kindergarten if
you were foolish enough to pick the
wrong family to have been born into that
is already going to impact metabolism of
your frontal cortex the thickness of it
the number of connections being made
there by age five you were already three
steps behind in terms of frontal
regulation of behavior because of SES
differences in this country so in that
realm the consequences I think are
enormous and hugely underappreciated
we're doing a good last few questions
yeah I'm a big fan I'll try not to kill
ate my question it has to do they're all
testosterone and then maybe the end
maybe some consequences of it what we
can do about it so if it's not related
to aggression but it's related to the an
increased reward for status where does
it act in the brain does it act in the
brain and then given that so many kids
may suffer especially these days with
impacts in the brain that might affect
their aggression as adults they have
some that you've given the balance in
the world today would a pharmaceutical
route be at all suggested before they
get before any kind of cognitive
training because it's a you know the
drug industry it will latch onto
anything but I feel like that's
something they haven't done I don't
think that's a long-term solution either
great ok which part of the brain has the
most receptors for testosterone the most
sensitivity to it makes total sense the
amygdala the amygdala is ground zero for
sensitivity to testosterone does
testosterone cause amygdala neurons to
fire to in effect invent aggressive
outputs not at all if and only if the
neurons are already firing testosterone
makes them fire faster testosterone does
not turn on the martial music it ups the
volume if it's already been turned on
now in terms of okay so let's make the
world a much better place here how about
we get rid of all those males okay maybe
not that okay so at least let's castrate
well now that's not very well what about
okay how about if we pharmacologically
block some of the effects of
testosterone and what you see there
besides it being mighty scary is a track
record of not working very well in a
number of places on earth the two places
where it is most been explored is big
surprise India and the state of Texas
there have been state ordered chemical
castration z' drugs which are given
which block testosterone receptors which
is in effect the equivalent of removing
testosterone from the scene usually for
intractably violent sexual offenders and
what the legislate and what the
literature shows is essentially it has
no effect whatsoever
because such aggression has very little
to do with aggression and has very
little to do with sexuality has a whole
lot to do with domination and fear and
issues like that pertinent to that you
take any male on earth of any known
species and take out his testes and that
almost certainly was the first
experiment ever done in endocrinology
about 10,000 years ago when like some
bull chase some people around the
backyard one time too many and they
wrestled him down and got rid of the
testes and suddenly he was a much more
tractable male if you castrate a male of
any species out there on the average
levels of aggression go down they never
go down to zero though and the critical
thing is the more experience that male
had being aggressive prior to castration
the more it's going to stay there
afterward in other words the more
experience you have with aggression the
less it is dependent on hormones and the
more it is a function of social learning
so that unfortunately or otherwise is
not much of a panacea there see final
question yeah final question hopefully a
more optimistic guy you know we get in
on a more optimistic note so you
mentioned the chronicity of the amygdala
enlarging with chronic stress and there
are things perhaps that we could do for
people who have experienced chronic
stress and thinking of people who have
been on multiple tours overseas and have
had to be exposed to horrendous things
and do her in two things so now that
we're having people do that more often
they're coming back and then ending
their lives and I'm wondering I know
people have tried meditation maybe yoga
might work but are there ways that even
with the example of testosterone and
really the amygdala that the role of the
amygdala and invoking aggression are
there ways that we can reduce the size
of the aggression or the size of the
amygdala yeah yeah the realm where
that's been most studied is with PTSD
combat trauma PTSD and sexual violence
PTSD where you see with the PTSD there
you get expansion of the amygdala it
becomes
hyper reactive it is over generalized
into it being a terrifying world out
there my lab for a while was doing some
genes that are be work on trying to
protect the amygdala from stress
hormones in ways that like as a circus
trick was kind of useful which is not
going to help a mammal anytime in the
next century or so my sense from sort of
the clinicians I've spent my time around
is that PTSD is not really anything
that's ever cured people learn how to
manage it how to contain it there is no
clear biological cure for it but
something fascinating and horrifying has
emerged in the literature in recent
years what is PTSD about it's obvious to
anyone have its fear its terror it's the
trauma of people trying to kill you of
watching your buddies killed around you
left and right it's it is anchored in
fear and the fear of the violence that
may harm you and those who you love but
the whole field has had to accommodate
an extraordinary finding in recent years
which is drone operators get PTSD they
get PTSD at the same grade as do
warriors out in the battlefield drone
operators sitting there living in some
suburb of Edwards Air Force Base
somewhere out there who get up in the
morning and remember to drop off the
clothing at the cleaners and get into
traffic jams and barely make it to work
on time and then sit in the simulator
there for eight hours blowing up people
on the other side of the planet and then
rush out at the end of the day to watch
their little girl in a ballet concert
and then go back to killing on the other
side of the globe the next day these
people have PTSD at the same rate as do
the actual soldiers and that is
completely challenged the notion of what
it's about it's not the fact that there
is nothing more abnormal and terrifying
to us than the notion of somebody
violently killing us that rather it's
the utterly bizarre and abnormal notion
of us killing someone else and that's
causing an enormous rethinking as to
what PTSD is about and lurking in there
is a little bit of optimism a man named
David Grossman who was a colonel in the
US military wrote a very influential
book called on killing analyze the
history of the extraordinary percentage
of people throughout Wars in the middle
of battle where their lives were on the
line at any given second who nonetheless
never fired their guns that there is an
enormous inhibition against doing that
after the Battle of Gettysburg there was
something like 14 thousand rifles left
next to the dead in the field there that
were collected the majority of them had
not been fired the majority of them had
been loaded repeatedly I'm just about to
shoot I better low I better load again I
better load again enormous in additions
against that and he argues that
somewhere in there is the greatest bit
of optimism asking people to kill
somebody faceless on the other side of
the planet that's easy
asking them to kill somebody whose eyes
they see from 10 feet away hand to hand
there is historically an enormous in
addition against that that's some room
for optimism there nonetheless in the
context of the US military now trains
more drone pilots than actual pilots oh
well remember what I was saying before
about castrating males or oh I don't
know just hold our breaths and try not
to fall into too much despair I don't
know I spend my time on the college
campus and I keep perhaps delusionally
trying to like console myself that this
is going to like generate a whole new
generation of activism like if it
produces 10 times the activism let's say
the 60s did it's still going to be an
uphill battle to undo the damage that's
going to be done in these next four
years I suspect so I know I don't have a
whole lot of grounds for not being
despairing in these times and you guys
get to live here and watch this day by
day I at least get to live out in la-la
land out in California and sort of
ignore it when we want to okay so thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]